underneath Grand Central Terminal
there's another terminal being created
in New York City the terminal itself
consists of two underground caverns that
are 60 feet high 60 feet wide and 1,200
feet long a project length underground
as it begins in Sunnyside yard and runs
underneath Long Island City and down to
the termination point at 37th Street is
approximately three miles the rock that
makes up Manhattan is primarily
Manhattan schist and there's a lot of
other different types of rock mixed in
with that
there's courts as pegmatite to Zen fit
light a lot of these rocks are like
20,000 psi and stronger that's why in
New York you can build such huge
skyscrapers and such deep tunnels
because the rock is such a high quality
it'll support itself and everything else
above it and below it family history and
the underground industries back to my
grandfather and then my father followed
in his footsteps and he was in the
underground so I just kind of gravitated
towards that
I really think about what it's going to
look like when it's done
the fact it's going to take another five
or six years to get to the point where
you can look back and say wow I was part
of this I were to leave now it would
just be kind of the end of another job
but if you get to stay that's finished
and see the finished product when people
are using it and it does we're supposed
to do and that's the best part of it